Los Angeles is a really interesting test
case it's a kind of Coliseum of Bank
crime in the late 1980s and 90s it was
enter mention was the was the bank
robbery capital of the world there was
that that statistic of a bank robbery
every 45 minutes of every workday is not
only accurate but is mind boggling
that's so many banks being robbed and
one of the there are many many factors
into what went into this rash of bank
crime in Los Angeles in the in the era
but one of the explanations and
something I think is quite interesting
in terms of misuse is that there was
this phenomenon known as a stop and
robbed and so a stop and rob is a
financial institution a bank a credit
union that kind of thing that's built at
the bottom of an off-ramp and at the
bottom of an on-ramp so you can stop and
rob get back on the freeway and and you
know be in Burbank and 20 minutes later
traffic depending but so the notion then
of course the transportation engineers
in the 1960s we're building freeways
they were being celebrated by
architectural writers like Ryan Urbana
MS this new sort of vernacular
experience of space in the city of LA
but in fact they're driving over a kind
of three dimensional Bank crime tool a
burglary tool that was the size and
shape of the city's freeway system I
think that kind of thing is quite
fascinating and now of course that's the
freeways but now let's go under the
surface of the earth into the storm
water networks so at the height of all
this Bank crime in 1986 and this is one
of my favorite stories in the book
there's a nod there was a still unsolved
crime that became known as the hole in
the ground gang and so there's a bank
that you can I think one of these
there's a laser pointer somewhere here
but so in this map actually okay this
isn't gonna work
so if you look to the right that's
actually looking north and so those are
the Hollywood Hills draining south down
into the city and amidst all of that at
the corner of sunset and Spaulding there
was a bank it's now a talent agency but
over the course of May and June of 1986
the bank employees began to notice all
these strange things occurring they
started noticing weird electrical
effects the telephone systems were short
in and out
the lights would turn on and off the
music would turn on early odd moments
they'd hear sounds that would then go
away they would call the police and say
there's something happening in the bank
like as you please come sort it out
but they would inspect the vaults alarms
would go off but nothing was happening
there's no one in the vault there's no
evidence of tampering and so the police
dismissed it as a large rat but the bank
employees began to think of it as a
poltergeist which I think is interesting
for at least two reasons one with which
is that it was still only two or three
years after the movie poltergeist came
out but also I love the fact that it was
it seemed more believable to them that
the bank would be haunted by the
supernatural figure then that there
might be burglars trying to get in from
below which touches back again again on
that notion that burglars are almost
these supernatural presences in the in
the in the built environment so what was
actually happening was that a crew of
individuals who are assumed in
retrospect to have made men burglary and
bank crime is a relatively not
universally but a relatively firmly
gendered undertaking but the their
knowledge of the storm sewer network by
following the old streams that came down
all the Hollywood Hills that would then
drain down through the old valleys of
Los Angeles there now they've now been
converted and canalized and turned into
the tunnel networks that extend for
miles and miles in this labyrinth
beneath the city eventually go all the
way down in this case to Bayona Creek
and then Bayona Creek then drains down
and so they are seen at the Pacific
Ocean they knew this is the series of
storm sewers so well and you can see in
these in these really beautiful
schematic diagrams that are available on
the internet if you if you have
nefarious things in mind but they knew
it so well that one of the FBI theories
actually was that the the team might
have been disgruntled Water and Power
employees that their knowledge of the
city was such that they would just
decided to to put it to more lucrative
use so to speak and take advantage of
the fact that they knew that a in Los
Angeles a is connected to B through this
sort of filigree of tunnels that we
don't see or even necessarily think
about and that if you control the the
sewers you can effectively get you can
control the banks from below so what was
happening was that they were driving a
group of suzuki four-wheelers
which are really no narrower than the
actual tunnels themselves so you've got
these individuals hunched over Suzuki
four-wheelers driving into the darkness
of Los Angeles night after night after
night for I think it was about three or
four weeks while they were building a
side tunnel and so you can see in this
photograph which is actually a
photograph of a photograph which was
shown to me by retired FBI agent named
William J Rader who's a really great guy
who I really enjoyed meeting but also
his his claim to fame sorry was that he
was he was he was the guy who was
shattered by Keanu Reeves when they made
the movie Point Break and so Keanu
Reeves and Bill Rader spent a couple
weeks together fighting crime in Los
Angeles but bill memorably pointed out
that Keanu never asked any questions and
none of the things that bill writer told
him about fighting bank crime made it
into the movie Point Break yeah it's a
it's not nominative determinism that
worked but so so Raydor met with
actually my wife and I at a cafe near
the Santa Monica Airport which is also
interesting cuz that's there's a scene
in Point Break set at the Santa Monica
Airport but in any case he had these
files and these photographs and so what
these guys have been doing it they they
they drove into and they kind of set up
a drilling camp underneath the surface
of Los Angeles and they began tunneling
a block about a block and a half two
blocks east to go underneath this Bank
and so they were very very good at
tunneling and so the second theory that
the FBI came up with was that they were
so good at tunneling that they might
actually have been disgruntled mining
engineers and so they had you know come
down from the mountains of the Sierra
you know with this sort of
battle-hardened vision of the earth's
sub-surface and they decided to put that
to use digging tunnels and robbing banks
so it was a very very good tunnel they
didn't use any reinforcement and in fact
it was quite a clever design they had
some improvisational hydrological
engineering as well because in order to
get rid of all that debris which is an
awful lot of you know excess rock and
sand and that kind of thing they would
build up a little dam inside the storm
water sewer Network excuse me so that as
even a trickle of water came down all
the Hollywood Hills that would
build up you know inch by inch by inch
and form a small reservoir under the
city that they've and then knock out all
of that water would then flow through
the tunnel it would wash away all the
debris would wash away their footprints
it would wash away sticks of gum DNA
evidence whatever it is that they might
might otherwise have had and kind of
clean the the crime scene afresh every
few nights the other really clever thing
that we're doing however was that they
were attaching their industrial tools to
the bank's own electrical network and so
like a kind of electrical jellyfish they
were tapping up into the dangling wires
and cables that controlled the bank
which is of course in retrospect that
makes sense of why the bank employees
were hearing music at nine o'clock at
night why the telephones are shorting
out it was not a poltergeist it was the
bank people spa or the the the hole in
the ground gang splicing in from below
but so once they actually got into the
bank you know they they they chose a
three-day weekend which is kind of a
cliche of heist films but it's actually
a great time to break into banks you
have more time they had set off the
alarm so many times that the police
didn't take it seriously so even though
they set off the vault alarm the bank
alarm is going off most of the weekend
nobody came I was just there was that
Bank up on sunset again it was the bank
that cried wolf and so they had three
entire days here's their actual tunnel
almost looks like something out of
Cappadocia and and I got away with it
[Music]